[Music]
tens of thousands of brazilians
demonstrated against the government last
weekend they're frustrated with the
handling of the pandemic so far nearly
600 000 brazilians have died from the
virus it's the highest death toll in the
world after the united states
many brazilians lost their jobs during
lockdowns while prices for rent food and
gas are on the rise
much of the south american giants
population has been left impoverished
with no way out in sight
hello and welcome to our copy 19 special
i'm monica jones good to have you with
us
well once projected to be the fifth
largest economy in the world brazil has
tumbled to number 12.
in the country's largest city sao paulo
entire families are now homeless because
they can no longer afford to pay the
rent the coronavirus pandemic hitting an
already fragile economy for many
brazilians it's the perfect storm
tresina used to live alone near downtown
sao paulo but when she could no longer
afford the rent she moved here on the
outskirts of the city where she now
lives with a niece
her daily battle is to buy food
this is the cheapest place to market in
her neighborhood yet she has to
negotiate prices the economic crisis
caused by the pandemic almost destroyed
her job as a freelance pollster
she's 61 years old has no husband or
children and is now running out of money
today i leave the market with my card
half full
before with the same money i would live
with a full cart and even with little
bugs in my hands
trezinha is just one example of what
millions of brazilians are experiencing
in these days according to the latest
authorities report just in the month of
july in the state of sao paulo there was
an 11 increase in food prices
the economic crisis is visible in the
streets of sao paulo a hundred people
live here in prasadese in the herd of
the city
here they sleep
cook
and eat
although there are no official figures
on the increase of homelessness in the
city ngos agree that it has skyrocket
surface foundation provides meals for
the homeless on a daily basis before the
pandemic they serve about 12 000 meals a
month in august 2021 the number doubled
now in 2021 many families arrive
women women with children
the cost of living in sao paulo has
risen dramatically over the last few
months
the institute of economic research
determined that electricity for example
increased 25 percent during the last
year
other items such as meat have registered
increases of up to 40 percent
we have inflation which destroys
purchasing power and on the other the
difficulties in the labor markets are
consequence of the pandemic in addition
politicians are not offering a solution
for families it is a critical moment
terezinha notes the rising of cost of
living her electricity bill for august
was 30 percent more expensive than the
previous month
debts keep her awake at nights
and the future for brazilians is not
bright according to official figures 14
of the population is unemployed as the
country reports the highest inflation
rates of the last 20 years and the
pandemic which caused the crisis shows
no signs of coming to an end
for more i'm joined by lina simmet
senior researcher on poverty and
inequality at human rights watch and she
joins us in new york good morning to you
i
just talked about a perfect storm and
normally we use that phrase when two
critical events come together in
brazil's case it's certainly the
coronavirus pandemic and what else
in fact there are many things that are
coming together in brazil but one of
them is certainly this huge inequality
crisis
um that has been boiling in in brazil
for for many years brazil is one of the
most unequal countries in the world and
the most unequal country in the region
and we see how the pandemic has really
exacerbated many of these existing
economic but also social inequalities in
terms of who has been pushed into
poverty who cannot afford food or water
um
the way they need to and now rely on um
sort of unsafe systems
um or the transfers that the government
has not provided to them sufficiently
where else in the world do we see
similar patterns especially now during
the pandemic
which is clearly driving poverty
in fact we see it all over the world see
the the covert pandemic has exacerbated
inequality
um in in european countries
in latin america as as much as in in
asia or or africa
and what we see is that in countries
that already had high inequality
um and lacking social protection systems
that's really where sort of the the
poverty crisis now
is among the worst because these these
systems really lack protection for
people who lost income lost jobs during
the pandemic and who have not recovered
and many of these workers
or many of these people work in the
informal economy and and just to say
that this is not a small share of the
population but in in many regions it's
the vast majority of the people working
informally without labor protections
without social protections when they
lose work when they lose income when
they fall ill
and just means having no income at all
and no ability to buy
um the things you need for for basic
survival
but clearly when a huge part of the
population suffers uh as you just
described in your research certainly
focuses on social protection measures
that fail to prevent people from falling
into poverty uh a lot has went has gone
wrong what can be done better uh next
time
i would say at the beginning of the
pandemic it was actually quite
encouraging to see how countries have
expanded existing protection measures or
introduced new ones
but
many of the flaws that we that we have
seen so clearly this last year those are
the ones that should be fixed moving
forward and that includes inadequate
coverage um where in the case of nigeria
just to give you an example
less than one percent of the population
received cash transfers
last year although more than 50 of the
population went hungry
um
in the amounts of social protection were
also often insufficient with
monthly payments of less than the
minimum wage or
or less than the the poverty threshold
in the respective countries
we
um
we also see that in
that in many instances there were issues
around corruption so the lack of
transparency where the money has gone
um and and therefore really relying sort
of on on informal systems since the
countries haven't set up sort of solid
structures for social protection systems
prior so really rethinking the need for
um investing in stronger systems moving
forward is absolutely essential right i
mean investing in stronger system there
are some who argue that we actually need
a global health governance rooted in
principles of justice and governed by
the common good and uh an institution to
represent and serve these common
interests as well as a moral
constitution for our planet's health
that's quite a tall order and i take it
the who does not fit the bill here what
exactly are we looking at
so
i would say in in two areas on the one
hand
around the global structures i think on
on vaccinations at least we need to
really push
powerful and higher income countries in
sharing the recipe of the vaccine with
others because the the inequalities
currently in vaccination coverage and
access
are enormous nowhere in high-income
countries you have 60
percent of the population
now vaccinated and in poor countries
it's just three percent right so really
much of the second quality
and the second one relates to social
protection here too um higher income
countries had a much greater possibility
to to invest and and protect their um
their populations and therefore there
should be more solidarity in building
out um
some sort of global fund for for social
protection all right lina seaman there
thank you so much for your time
thank you
time for one of your questions now
here's derek williams
are there any studies showing that air
pollution increases mortality from covet
19
long-term exposure to significant levels
of air pollution is a major factor in
death
and suffering worldwide the who
estimates that it kills around
seven million people a year globally
that's more than the number of deaths
caused by infectious diseases and and
similar to the number associated with
smoking so
it's no wonder that many studies have
looked at the links between air
pollution and covet 19 during the course
of the pandemic
and it shouldn't come as much of a
surprise that a potentially serious
respiratory disease
can pretty clearly affect people a lot
worse who are regularly exposed to high
levels of air contaminants
let's look a little closer at just one
of those studies which searched for
correlations
between air pollution and covid cases in
england last summer
it found even after adjusting for
confounding factors like like population
density and age and income
that in areas with regular high levels
of toxic gases and particulate matter
uh places like london or the midlands
region
residents were significantly more likely
to be infected with saris kobe 2 or to
die from covet 19
than people in other parts of the
country the association was
particularly strong when it came to
areas with high levels of the nitrogen
oxides and and very fine particulate
matter
that mostly comes from burning fuel
the researchers concluded that even a
small increase in air pollution had a
big effect on both covet infectivity
and mortality in the country and and
there are plenty of other studies from
other countries that back up
and corroborate those results
and that's all for this edition of our
copied 19 special from me and the team
thanks for watching
[Music]
you